before i called jonathan ashworth to ask
his urgent question i want to remind the
house that her skin may states
that good temper and moderation of the
characteristics of the parliamentary
language
while the context in which particular
phrase is used is important
asking may also says that there are
certain expressions
which when used in respect of the
members are regarded
with particular seriousness generally
leading to prompt intervention from the
chair
and often requests on the member to
withdraw the words
one example is making a charge of
uttering a deliberate falsehood
in other words members shall not accuse
other members of lying
depending on the context it may
well be in order to quote the views of
others but members should not themselves
state or
imply that other members are lying there
are ways in such
issues can be debated in the house by
means of a substantive motion
but not part of an urgent question i now
call
jonathan ashley to ask his urgent
question ask the secretary of state for
health to update the house
on the pandemic preparator preparedness
of the department of health and social
care
i now call the secretary of state for
health
thank you very much mr speaker and um
mr speaker what we've done to handle
this coronavirus pandemic
has been unprecedented in modern times
throughout we have been straight with
people
and straight with this house about the
challenges
that we as a nation face together
the nation in my view has risen to these
challenges
of course there were unprecedented
difficulties
that come with preparation for an
unprecedented
event but mr speaker this pandemic isn't
over yet
our vaccination program has reached 73
of the adult population but that means
that more than a quarter still haven't
been jabbed
43 percent of adults have had both jabs
but that means that more than half are
yet to get the fullest
possible protection that two jabs gives
yesterday we saw 3180 new cases of
coronavirus
the highest since the 12th of april
but thanks to the power of vaccination
in which i have always believed the link
from cases to hospitalizations and to
deaths
is being severed around 90 percent of
those in hospital
in hot spot areas have not yet had both
jabs
so the continued delivery of the
vaccination effort
and the ongoing work to control the
virus through
testing tracing and isolation
these are vital yesterday
we saw the opening of vaccinations to
all those aged 30 and above and i'm
delighted to tell the house that the
vaccination program
is on track to meet its goal to offer a
jab to
all adults by the end of july and
mr speaker it has met every goal
that we have set because setting and
meeting ambitious targets is how you get
stuff done in government we have many
challenges
as a nation still to come i know and one
of the things i've learned
is the best way through is to work
together
with a can-do spirit of positive
collaboration the team the team who have
worked so
hard together to get us this far deserve
our highest praise
i am proud of everyone in my department
all those working in healthcare and in
public health
the armed forces who fought on this home
front the volunteers who stood in cold
car parks with a smile
colleagues across the house who have
done their bit
and most of all the british people
and whether it's the science or the nhs
or people queuing for vaccines in their
droves
britain is rising to this challenge we
have come together
as one nation and we will overcome
senate secretary of state jonathan
ashworth mr speaker families who lost
loved ones will have noticed that the
secretary of state
in his opening remarks did not respond
to any of the specific
allegations from yesterday allegations
which are grave and serious that the
prime minister
is unfit for office that his inaction
meant tens of thousands
needlessly died allegations from dominic
cummings that he specifically
is accused of misleading colleagues an
allegation from mr cummings
uh mr speaker on our preparedness and
lack of protection for people
in care homes now these allegations from
cummings
are either true and if so the secretary
of state
potentially stands in breach of the
ministerial code and the nolan
principles
or they are false and the prime minister
brought a fantasist
and a liar into the heart of downing
street which
is it families who have lost loved ones
deserve full answers from him today
is he ashamed that he promised a
protective shield around
care homes and over 30 000 care home
residents have died
why were 25 000 elderly people
discharged from hospitals into care
homes without any test
did he tell downing street in march that
people discharged from hospital
had been tested even though it wasn't
until 15th of april
that there was a requirement for testing
to take place
in public he has often claimed that
little was known of asymptomatic
transmission
at the time so testing wasn't necessary
but sage in january
flagged evidence of asymptomatic
transmission a study in the lancet in
february
flagged it on march the 5th the cmo said
there may well be a lot of people who
are infected and have no symptoms
so why didn't he insist on a
precautionary approach and test
all going into care homes on 6th of may
at the dispatch box he claimed
that it is safer for them to go into a
care home
12 000 people had died in these early
months
how can he justify that comment in april
he told the house
that what is important is that infection
control procedures are in place in that
care home
but care homes like the nhs struggled
with the most desperate of ppe
shortages and he was telling us in march
from this dispatch box that supplies
were extensive
but apparently in private in downing
street was blaming simon stevens for
lack of ppe
but the reality is him and his
department was responsible for ppe
and the nao report said the supplies
were inadequate
850 healthcare workers died how many
could have been saved
had they had ppe families loved
lost ones and have been let down by this
government this prime minister
and this health secretary but the truth
matters
these families and the country deserve
clear answers
from the health secretary and the prime
minister today
segregate well thank you mr
mr speaker the these allegations that
were put yesterday and repeated by the
right honourable gentleman are serious
allegations
and i welcome the opportunity to come to
the house to put
formally on the record that these
unsubstantiated
allegations around honesty are not true
and that i've been straight with people
in public and in private
throughout every day since i began
working
on the response to this pandemic last
january
i've got up each morning and asked what
must i do
to protect life that is the job
of a health secretary in a pandemic
we've taken
an approach of openness transparency
and explanation of both what we know and
what we don't know i was looking at it
this morning since last january i've
attended this house mr speaker
over 60 times with the prime minister
we have together hosted 84 press
conferences
i've answered 2667 contributions to this
house
and answer questions from colleagues the
media and the public
and we'll keep on with this spirit
of openness and transparency throughout
as well as coming to the house today
i'll be answering
questions and hosting another press
conference later
now sometimes what we've had to say
hasn't been easy
we've had to level with people when it's
been tough
when things have been going in the wrong
direction
and also we have learned throughout
we've applied that learning
both to tackling this pandemic and
making sure that we're as well prepared
in the future
as possible but beyond all this
what matters remains the same
getting vaccinated getting tested
delivering for our country
overcoming this disease and saving lives
and that is what matters to the british
people
let's go to the chair of the state
commitment jeremy thank you mr speaker
the house should know that when at
yesterday's joint
select committee hearing serious
allegations were made
we asked for evidence to be provided
and until such evidence is provided
those allegations should be treated as
unproven in the meantime we are in the
midst of the pandemic
and we need the health secretary to be
doing his job
with his customary energy and commitment
so i want to ask him about comments made
this morning by neil ferguson on the
today programme
he said that the indian variant is now
dominant in the majority of local
authority areas and indeed is
the dominant variant of the virus
and that june the 21st as an opening
date was now in the balance
given how desperate businesses are up
and down the country
to return to normal what additional
measures
can he take in the short term to make
sure in terms of search
testing in terms of the vaccine rollout
in terms of improvements to test and
trace
that we really are able to open up as
everyone wants on june the 21st
state thank you very much mr speaker
well it is true
that the indian variant is spreading
across the country um and estimates vary
as to
what proportion of the new cases each
day
are the variant first identified in
india
which is more transmissible now my
assessment is
that it is too early now to say yet
whether we can take the full step four
on the 21st of june
like him i desperately want us to but we
will only do that if it's safe
we will make a formal assessment ahead
of the
14th of june as to what step we can take
on the 21st and in that we will be
both driven by the data we will be
advised
on and guided by the science and we will
be fully
transparent both with this house and
with the public in those decisions
that's the approach we've taken that's
the approach he and his select committee
would expect
and it's what we'll deliver let's go to
snp spokesperson martin day martin
thank you mr speaker in dominic cummings
opening statement yesterday
he said that truth is that senior
ministers senior officials senior
advisers felt disastrously short of the
standards that the public has a right to
expect
of its government in a crisis like this
when the public needed us most we failed
we then had a litany of evidence that
the disease wasn't taken
seriously in february last year further
compounded by the ignoring of sage
advice in september to lock down
and resulting in a worse second wave
does the health secretary agree that the
uk government failed the public
and had he acted sooner how many lives
could have been saved
or restrictions could have been avoided
will he act urgently to prevent further
unnecessary suffering and death in our
immediate future
by holding a comprehensive public
inquiry immediately
so state thank you very much mr speaker
well i've been working on this pandemic
since january
of last year that's when we began
work before the disease was even evident
in this country that's when we kicked
off work on the
vaccine i was told at first that it
would
typically take five years to develop a
vaccine
and i insisted that we drove at that as
fast as we possibly
could and i'm delighted at the progress
on that that we've been able
to make of course it is right that we
learn
from everything that we understand and
everything that we see
and all of the scientific advances we
should do that
all the way through this idea that we
should wait for an inquiry
in order to learn is wrong but of course
it's also
right that at the appropriate time we
then go through
all that happened in order to ensure
that we're as best prepared
for the inevitable pandemics of the
future let's go to sherlin mccrory
shirley thanks
thank you mr speaker um i'd like to
thank my right honourable friend for his
visit to the royal cornwall hospital in
truro earlier this week where we
met with staff and toured the site of
the new oncology wing and also
looked at the state of the art plans for
the new women and children's
hospital one of our 40 new hospitals
manifesto promise
given the gravity of the situation the
government faced at the beginning
of the pandemic and considering we now
know there was a hugely disruptive force
in the form of dominic cummings i'd like
to congratulate ministers not least my
right honourable friend for staying
focused
on the evidence presented by the experts
at the time as events changed quickly
can my right honourable friend assure me
that he will ignore
unsubstantiated westminster gossip and
stay focused
on delivering the vaccine rollout and
our manifesto promises
well thank you very much uh mr speaker i
think that's what the public expects us
to do
i had an absolutely brilliant visit to
cornwall on
on monday of this week and it was a
pleasure to go to
trilisk and to see my honourable friend
there
and to talk about the new women and
children's hospital that we're building
as part of the biggest ever investment
in healthcare in cornwall is delivering
on these priorities on which we were
elected
and of course dealing with this pandemic
and keeping people safe
that is what the public want to see it's
what the expectations of the public are
and it's my total focus if i'm withdrawn
shall we go to mike wood
mike mr speaker there was no manual to
guide governments going into this new
global pandemic
but most people feel the government
responded as well as anybody could
in particular over the last six months
government has worked well together to
deliver a phenomenal amount of testing
one of the best vaccine rollouts in the
world is the secretary of state aware
of anything that's changed during that
time to help the way the government has
worked on improving the kovid response
tuesday
well i think all i'd say to my honorable
friend
is that it is very difficult
responding to an unprecedented challenge
of this scale but i think that over the
past
six months people have seen that
governing has become a little easier
and we're being able to deliver let's go
to yasmin qureshi
yasmin mr speaker
in february i called for localized
community-based vaccination centers
and i want to pay tribute to dr helen
wall bolton ccg
nhs and the volunteers for the rollout
of the vaccine
last week my concessions were wrongfully
accused of vaccine hesitancy
and then we had a quasi lockdown that no
one knew about
and many people's travel plans were
thrown in chaos
my constituents can forgive the
government for that
but i am sure that i speak for the
country when i say that we cannot
forgive
tens of thousands of people who died and
didn't need to die
the chilling words of dominic are coming
will the secretary still tell me when
will the prime minister and others be
investigated
by the police for alleged corporate
manslaughter
and why did we not follow the example of
new zealand
where they managed to control it without
a minimum of number of deaths
no mr speaker but the uh what i would
say to the people of bolton
is that the people of bolton have again
risen to this challenge the number of
vaccinations happening in bolton right
now is phenomenal
tens of thousands every single day and
it is it is heartening to see the cues
of people coming forward both for
testing
and for vaccinations in bolton this has
not been an easy pandemic anywhere
but it's been especially difficult in
bolton and i in particular want to pay
tribute to the leadership
of bolton council and councillor david
greenl
who's done such a remarkable job in very
difficult circumstances
let's go to slain saxby chile thank you
mr speaker
i would like to thank my right
honourable friend for visiting north
devon district hospital this week where
he personally thanked the wonderful
staff and discuss future development
plans
whilst this government has worked
tirelessly to save lives protect our nhs
labour have spent the last year
flip-flopping over curfews lockdowns
schools and our borders
and i'm sure my right honourable friend
shares my disappointment that even now
the party opposite is still more
interested in playing politics
than working constructively with us so
can i seek his reassurance that as we
emerge from the pandemic
he is committed to lowering nhs waiting
times and improving access to vital gp
services
as he continues to make sure that
everybody who needs care
gets care secretly thank you very much
mr speaker absolutely i am and gp access
in particular is very important and this
morning
i met with the british medical
association
and the british medical association gp
leadership to talk about what more we
can do to strengthen access to gps these
are the sorts of things that matter to
our constituents
as does the new hospital that we're
going to build
in my honourable friends constituency it
was a wonderful visit
uh earlier this week on tuesday in devon
and it's been great going around the
country looking at what we can do to
further invest in the nhs
to strengthen our nhs to support our nhs
to deliver better care
and north devon doesn't have a better
champion than the honorable lady as for
what she said about the opposition all i
can say is that sometimes the right
honourable
gentleman has constructive criticism
he's generally had a good crisis
and maybe he'll return to that approach
soon manira wilson
manira thank you very much mr speaker
quite the opposite of putting a shield
around them
we sent people with covid back to the
care homes
these were the words of the prime
minister's former chief advisor
yesterday
if true this is one of the biggest
scandals and tragedies
of the pandemic so can the secretary of
state
please confirm when testing on discharge
from hospitals
into care homes was routinely offered
and will he apologize to the tens of
thousands of bereaved family members
whose relatives died in care homes show
mistake
well it has been a incredibly difficult
time
for those who work in and live in care
homes throughout this
pandemic that's been true across the
world
and i want to pay tribute to the staff
who work in social care who've done
so much um it is it was of course a
difficult
challenge especially at the start when
many characteristics of this virus
were unknown and as i've answered many
times in this house
we have published the full details of
the approach
that we take and that we took
and we worked with the care home sector
as much as possible to keep people safe
and we followed
the clinical advice on the appropriate
way forward
lock thank you very much uh mr speaker
can i take the secretary of state back
to something he said in his statement
which i think actually is
going to be of the most concern to uh my
constituents
and the country in the days and weeks
ahead which is what he said about the
b161 7.2 very at first discovered in
india now we're about to see an increase
in cases as we open up that is
inevitable
but the important thing is the is
breaking that link between cases
hospitalization and death my
understanding of all of the evidence
that currently exists is that the
vaccines we have
are very effective in stopping
serious disease including with that
b1617.2 right now if that remains the
case
then on the 15th of june does he agree
that there would be no reason
why we wouldn't be able to open up fully
on the 21st of june
that's the important question to which
we need an answer
so that is literally the most important
question
to which we do not yet have a full
answer the data that we have is that
in the hotspot areas around one in ten
of those in hospital are people who've
had both jabs
but that is of course a function both of
the protection that you get
from the vaccine against this variant
and
also of the age profile of those who are
catching
the disease and those who haven't been
vaccinated include those
who are um old enough to have been
offered the jab
and those who have not yet been offered
the jab now the fact that 90
are people who have not yet been double
vaccinated
gives us a high degree of confidence
that the vaccine
is highly effective but it also shows
the fact there's 10 percent
who have been double vaccinated that it
isn't 100
effective we already knew this but we're
better able to calibrate as we see these
these data we will learn more about this
over the net of the forthcoming
uh week or two and before we make an
assessment
and publish an assessment um ahead of
the uh
the 14th of june um
about the uh the what the data's saying
about taking the step
uh that is penciled in for not before
the 21st
jim shovel thank
for all that he has done uh to deal with
the coronavirus
disease and also to to to the role out
of the vaccine
mr uh speaker my mother-in-law died last
year during the corona virus on the
monday she was sitting in the hospital
and five days later we lost her
now we don't blame anybody mr speaker
and i want to put that on record
but we alone but we do miss her every
day and we continue to do so
i just want to ask they they said
yesterday this there are others
who have questions and there are others
who
have questions that they need answers to
in northern ireland
and i just want to ask the question the
quickly they state this question
our prime minister has committed himself
to an inquiry the secretary of state
hasn't committed himself to that inquiry
and i want to ensure
that those people from northern ireland
who have lost loved ones
and have questions questions sincere
questions not to blame anybody mr gently
speaker mr speaker
but just take ask the questions and get
those answers
uh i can't hear assure us that people
from northern ireland who have those uh
questions can and will be part of that
inquiry thank you
so much yes of course uh mr speaker um
i'm sure that he like me will welcome
the fact that this morning northern
ireland has been able to open up
vaccination
to all adults over the age of 18 showing
the progress
that we're able to make working together
with the uk vaccination program
and the local delivery through the
department of
health and social care in in northern
ireland on the question of the
inquiry of course the inquiry must
and will cover the entire united kingdom
and in those in the uh three nations
that have devolved administrations of
course it will have to
cover the activities both of the uk
government
and of the devolved responsibilities
how exactly how that is structured is
yet to be determined and will be done in
consultation with the devolved
administrations but as he rightly says
it is vital that we use the inquiry
to ensure that people can ask questions
and get answers
in all parts of this united kingdom
let's go to derek thomas derek
thank you mr speaker we all recognize
everyone recognizes lessons that can be
learned as a result of this pandemic
and we don't necessarily need to wait
for the inquiry to take place
will the secretary of state believe
share my view that
integration of health and social care is
critical
is something that would absolutely be a
lesson to be learned from the pandemic
and
i was so delighted to welcome the
secretary of state to the old city on
monday the first we understand
of a health visitor of any time and uh
health secretary
so will he um affirm the model that we
are developing on the outside
to integrate health and social care and
prove the outcomes for everyone living
on those islands
is right for those islands but also a
model that could be used
elsewhere across the united kingdom so
say
yes absolutely it was it was an enormous
pleasure to go to the alsacilli on
on monday morning i didn't know that i
was the first health secretary ever to
visit
the aisles of scilly but frankly it's so
wonderful i'd really quite like to be
back
before too long um the um the point that
he
makes about the integration of health
and social care is happening
on silly it's important on silly but
it's actually a lesson for everywhere
and it's a discussion i was having with
the new
uh conservative-led cornwall council as
well
the first ever majority-led
conservative-led
cornwall council and the team there um
and on the island silly are doing a
great job at integrating health
and social care and in on silly in
particular where they need investment in
their
health infrastructure the support
because it is more remote than almost
anywhere else
these things we will deliver and what i
can tell
my honorable friend is that throughout
the
length and breadth of this country we
will invest
in the nhs and we will integrate health
and social care
and um and and the the outside could
hope for no better advocate than him
right let's go to neil hamby neil
thank you mr speaker yesterday's
revelations have only served to
reinforce what many have suspected
a tale of chaos deception dishonesty and
failure
including the reckless suggestion of
herd immunity and chickenpox parties
while so many watched aghast the
secretary of state chose to respond to
these very serious allegations by
claiming
he had been too busy saving lives to
even bother
my enduring memory of the secretary of
state yesterday will be of him quite
literally
running away from his responsibilities i
want to focus my questions on one
vitally important matter that emerged
yesterday
regarding deaths in care homes did the
secretary of state as alleged
categorically tell mr cummings and
unspecified others
that people would be tested before being
transferred into care homes
and if he did not why then was transfer
without testing the adopted policy
across
england and the devolved governments
including scotland
on the 17th of october last year i asked
the secretary of state to consider
tendering his resignation
surely if all of these allegations are
substantiated
he must do so
mr speaker so many of the allegations
yesterday were
unsubstantiated um and i think the point
that um
the most important point that the
honorable gentleman just made
was that the the scottish government
with its responsibilities for
social care also
had to respond to the same challenges
and dilemmas
that we did as did other countries
across europe
and across the world when we were
driving
incredibly hard as one united kingdom to
increase
testing volumes and we successfully
increased testing volumes
including through the important use of
the hundred thousand testing target
which had a material impact
on accelerating the increase of testing
and because of this increased testing we
were then
able to spread the use of tests more
broadly
it was the same challenge for the
administration in edinburgh
as it was um here in westminster
and the best way to rise to these
challenges is to do so working together
we have a lying connection with dr
andrew morrison so we'll go straight to
carolina because caroline
thank you mr speaker the families of the
bereaved deserve better than the
grotesque pantomime of the cummings
evidence session yesterday
at the very least they deserve the
publication of the internal
lessons learnt review my constituent
whose father died from covert acquired
in hospital
wrote to me to say that the refusal to
release it is and i quote
an insult to bereaved family members who
in the midst of our own suffering are
determined to prevent other families
from experiencing the loss that we have
she's right because the big question is
not just about mistakes the government
made last march
but why ministers never learn from those
errors and continue on a path
that risks lives and livelihoods so he
says he's being straight with the public
in this house
so as continued government negligence
risks a third wave of the pandemic
will he finally publish that review
urgently
not least so that it can become
scrutinized before restrictions are due
to be lifted
next month thank you very much mr
speaker of course we
learn lessons all the way through and we
follow the scientific developments that
teach us more about the
uh this uh this virus all the way
through
and and then we will also have a
full enquiry afterwards
to make sure that we can learn further
lessons uh from the
for the future the thing i didn't quite
understand about the honorable ladies
question
um is how why she didn't
refer to the single most important
program that is saving lives which is
the vaccination program
and she should be urging her
constituents and others to come forward
and get the jab because that is our way
out of this pandemic
it can be um thank you mr speaker thanks
to this government and the vaccine task
force led by kate bingham
it is britain who's led the way in
vaccinations and britain who has given
so much to the world
through our vaccination technology and
innovation globally over one billion
jumps have now been given
most of those either pfizer modern or
oxford astrazeneca
and it is this government that backed
oxford university with over 60 million
pounds of funding
to give the gift of hope to the world so
can i thank the secretary of state for
his efforts and his remarkable
achievements in this regard and if i may
ask him this
when does he think the t-side vaccine
novavax will be approved by the mhra
so um the last point is very tempting
but i will leave it to the independent
regulator to
uh to make that decision and to
determine the timing of that decision
but we're all very excited about the
progress
of the t-side vaccine as he calls it the
the novavax vaccine but he's also right
to raise this point about vaccinations
around the world
and this is a critical role that the uk
can be very proud of having played
because of the investment we made
in the oxford astrazeneca vaccine right
at the start of this pandemic
and because of the way that along with
oxford university
and astrazeneca we have decided together
to make this vaccine available at costs
around the world
and i can tell the house with an update
that there
have now been over 450 million
doses of the oxford astrazeneca vaccine
deployed around the world
at cost that is the single biggest gift
to the world that we could make with
respect to vaccines
it is because of the attitude that this
government took
working with our one of our greatest uh
universities
working with one of our greatest
industrial partners it is another
example of the big
team effort that is helping in this case
the whole world to get out of this panda
let's go to muhammad jason mohammed
thank you very much mr speaker in a pmq
in july
i raised the concerns of a care home
owner in bedford
who was told as late as the 21st of may
that if she refused to accept the return
from hospital of a covered
positive patient they would be
discharged to an unfamiliar home
i know the secretary of state is
desperate to dismiss mr cummingsworth
you know events on care homes
but to do so would mean calling the care
home owner a liar
who is responsible for these high
numbers of unnecessary debts
the health secretary or the prime
minister
well mr speaker as i said we've answered
this question
many times before and what i'd add to
those answers is that
it's another example of constantly
learning about
the the virus and as we learned the
impact of asymptomatic transmission in
particular
so we changed the protocols in care
homes over the summer
and put in place the winter plan that
led to a greater degree
of protection in care homes over the
the second peak and we're constantly
looking
to make sure that we can learn as much
as possible and work with the sector
to help people stay as safe as possible
well welcome
thank you very much mr speaker and uh
when it comes to the health secretary
i'm a fan those
those are those are not my effusive
words they come from some of the highest
levels amongst our health team
in bolson like colleagues on both sides
of this house
we've been on countless calls with the
health secretary with
upwards of a hundred mps on many
occasions and like today
he has taken the time to respond or come
back after each and every
interaction with helpful advice and
solutions i say this in private
i say this in public and i said in
today's times red box that's a plug
these last two weeks he has thrown the
health department's kitchen sink
at bolton to help us through the recent
variant
driven spike can he provide an update on
the current situation
as well as giving continued commitment
to work hard for bolson
i presume it's your red boxer refers to
secretary of state
there are issues around bolton in my red
box very uh regularly
uh mr mr speaker i was i was waiting on
tenterhooks
to find out if as well as his
constituent being a fan
my old friend is a fan and um uh i i
i'll um maybe he can tell me later
in private but he makes a very serious
point which is that
we have a significant uh challenge in
bolton right now
we have a high rate of covid
transmission and we have done everything
we possibly can
to support boltonians to solve this
problem
with increased vaccination and it's
great to see the
huge enthusiasm for vaccination and the
cues
of people coming forward and i would say
to everybody in bolton
please come forward if you haven't had
both jabs
yet and secondly the testing effort
which has seen people come forward
and get tested and is helping us to
break the chains of transmission that is
the
approach that we're trying to take now
that we've built this huge
vaccine and testing infrastructure over
the past few months
let's go to matt weston matt
thank you mr speaker the secretary of
state claims that he has always been
straight
yet his response to my question last
week suggests otherwise
remember he was not straight over the
need for higher grade
ffp3 masks for our frontline nhs and
care workers
he was not straight over the need for
the public to wear masks at the start of
the pandemic
and he has not been straight over tested
trace such as his fabricated test
numbers
last april given yesterday's revelations
however
will the secretary of state apologize to
warwickshire families
for the 344 excess deaths
resulting from his decision to disarm
discharge hospital patients
directly into our care homes
serviced it i don't recognize those
figures but i do recognize the enormous
challenge
of keeping people safe in care homes in
the height of a pandemic
in unprecedented circumstances but what
the other thing that i would
say uh mr speaker is that
in the honorable gentleman's
constituency
we are building one of the biggest
testing laboratories
that this country has ever seen if not
the biggest
and the ability to have this huge
testing capacity is an asset that this
country has
which will mean not only we can help
tackle the virus
now spot the new variants
and make sure that we have an
understanding of where it might be
popping up like for instance in bolton
but also that we're better prepared in
the future
and what i'd like to do with the
on-world gentleman is work
with him to deliver this brilliant
laboratory in lemington spa and to make
sure that it is a model for how we do
diagnostics
for the future and i think that working
together is the best approach we can
take
we've got an audio only with dr andrew
morrison andrew
thank you mr speaker uh how does my
right oral friend account for the
yawning difference between the account
given to the slate committee yesterday
and rehearsed by the opposition today
and the balanced and objective accounts
that continue to be given by the
national audit office
on this pandemic notably uh the one
published earlier this month
detailing the government's response to
the pandemic and can i ask him
specifically
how he will be taking forward one of the
principal recommendations
of that report that we need to be
planning
for a sustainable health care workforce
that can
be organized at pace in the event
that there is a future emergency of this
sort
and particularly individuals who are
properly skilled and updated
to fill gaps that may arise as a result
of a future pandemic
he's quite right on both points mr
speaker not only have we been
transparent and account and accountable
to this house
and straight with this house about the
challenges um
but we have also welcomed the national
audit office
into government throughout this pandemic
and it has published repeatedly for
instance it published on
uh ppe showing that we successfully
avoided a national outage
of ppe it has reported on every aspect
of the pandemic and we have learned the
lessons
that are within those those reports and
i recommend to the house the national
audit office's latest publication which
summarized all of these
uh lessons and uh learnings and he's
absolutely right that one of those
is making sure that we have high quality
workforce planning for the future
speaker has my right honourable friend
noted the various ironies
of yesterday's committee it must be
personally difficult for him and others
who
needlessly defended someone so willing
to throw them into the road
full of those presumably behind wheels
of those testing their eyesight
but mr speaker is not the greater irony
the
strange epiphany in many who have gone
from regarding the prime minister's
former advisor as a latter-day king
herod
whose words and deeds could not be
trusted into a prophet
who fresh from the world who fresh from
the wilderness
brings with him supposed truths written
on tablets of stone mr speaker
irony of ironies all is irony
i think mr speaker what the constituents
who we serve
are looking for is a government that is
focused four
square on delivering for them getting us
out of this pandemic
and building back better and
observations on ironies
i will leave to my honourable friend
let's go to chris stevens
chris thank you mr speaker delaying a
public inquiry until 2022
could uh see the rewriting of memories
the potential loss of key documents and
a lack of the full transparency
with the decisions that were taken based
upon the evidence
given the seriousness of the testimony
of mr cummings comments including these
statements
the scale of the disaster is so big that
people need to understand how the
government failed them
and learn from it does the secretary of
state agree with me
that i we need to now see a quicker
start
to a public inquiry than the government
currently plans to
save state no right let's go to
peterborough
um thank you mr speaker what do we know
about the secretary of state
well we know he's exceptionally hard
working that every day
he woke up to try and save lives he's
been exceptionally good at coming to
this house
and answering questions he's also had
held press conferences
and answered questions from journalists
yet yesterday we had
some outrageous claims by an
unelected spad who broke
covet regulations admitted he leaked
stuff to the bbc
and by his own omission wasn't fit to be
a number 10 down history
mr pico would the secretary of state
agree with me the only mistake the prime
minister made
in this pandemic is he didn't fire
dominic comings
early enough safe state
thank you very much mr speaker i'm very
grateful to my right-hand
friend for that uh question and i'll
continue to
compliment him once i think of how to
respond um
the um the the honest truth is
that from the start i've been totally
focused
on how to get out of this pandemic
it is absolutely true that the operation
and functioning of government has got
easier this last
six months and i think all the public
can see that
and we are laser focused
on getting through this getting this
country out of it delivering
that vaccine program which we've now
been working on for almost a year and a
half
which is remarkable and i pay tribute to
all those who've been working on this
effort the way
to fight a pandemic is by bringing
people together
and inspiring hope
let's go to russian alley russian nara
thank you mr speaker 519 residents
in my borough of tower hamlets lost
their lives to covet
in my own family we lost five of our
relatives
and their family members are grappling
with that loss to this day
the hearings yesterday were incredibly
distressing
mr cummings has admitted to government
failures in handling the pandemic
and said it meant tens of thousands
of people died who didn't need to die
out of respect to those families that
what over 128
000 families who've lost their lives
will the secretary of state
admit to the failures today and
apologize
and will he instead of a simple no to
the earlier question
will he bring forward urgently the date
for the inquiry because families like
ours
and my constituents and all those who've
lost loved ones
up and down the country deserve answers
now
and they deserve for lessons to be
learned
so that these mistakes are never made
again
mr speaker um the pandemic has taken
far too many people away far too soon
and that's happened in
in her family and it's happened in mine
and she's absolutely right that we need
to ensure
that we learn as a country how
um how to prepare as well as we possibly
can for
pandemics in the future because it is
likely
that pandemics will become more frequent
not less
and it is vital that people have the
opportunity to get
answers and we must learn the lessons
all the way through not just wait till
afterwards
and we must have a full enquiry
afterwards so that we can ensure that
every detail
is assessed and that everybody has the
opportunity to ask those
those questions and i think that is the
right approach
thank you mr speaker on sunday i had the
absolute joy of going to the
winding wheel in chesterfield and
receiving my first vaccine
will my right honourable friend thank
all of the volunteers and staff at the
winding wheel
for what they have been doing and can he
tell me what uh monitoring has been
happening at the department of health
of an outbreak of opportunism and
revisionism
that seems to be spreading through
opposition politicians
and if it helps i have an idea of who
patient zero might be for that outbreak
captain hindsight if you will
so mistake you're delighted my
honourable friend has had his first
jab i didn't know he was old enough yet
but the
um but um it it is very important that
you take decisions in government based
on the information that you have at the
time
and of course afterwards you can go and
assess based on information you have
afterwards but you can only take
decisions on the information that you
have
and that's why an unprecedented crisis
like this leads to
unprecedented challenges and what you
have to do is tackle those challenges
as best as you possibly can let's go to
barbara keeley
barbara thank you mr speaker
at the start of this pandemic kovi 19
was seeded into care homes by a
discharge policy which required
care homes to take asymptomatic patients
a letter from kent and medway ccg to
care providers dated 26 march 2020
made clear they were asked to take such
patients whether they had been tested or
not
yesterday the joint select committee
inquiry heard that the prime minister
was told
by the secretary of state that testing
would be in place for these patients
so i'm asking quite specifically did he
know
that the discharge process did not
require testing and did he
sign off this policy which led to
thousands of avoidable deaths of
vulnerable people
and many deaths of care staff so
well the i've answered this question
many times and the challenge is
that we had to build the testing
capacity and at that time
of course i was focused on protecting
people in care homes
and in building that testing capacity so
that we
had the daily tests to be able to ensure
that availability was more widespread
that is at the heart of the importance
of the then 100 000
target and net we're now up to a
position where we have
uh millions of tests available per day
andrew [ __ ]
thank you mr speaker surely mr speaker
it cannot be in
anyone's interest least of all those who
are mourning
loved ones for the mob to descend and
judge and preoccupy my right honourable
friend
at this point in the pandemic the
government has made clear
there will be a full inquiry and that is
when
hindsight can and should prevail oh
surely it is in all our interests that
he gets on
with his work bringing his experience to
bear saving
lives and carrying out this excellent
vaccination program
in which connection will he meet a
cross-party delegation
of west midlands metropolitan leaders
who are keen to work
with him to deliver these common
objectives
so state yes mr speaker these are common
objectives the way my right on
friend puts it is absolutely spot on and
i'd be delighted to meet with him
and the west midlands leaders to ensure
that we can roll out the vaccination
effort as quickly and effectively as
possible in order both to save lives
and get us out of this pandemic let's go
to bury sherman
barely thank you mr speaker
is the uh secretary of state aware that
by and large many of us have been in the
parliament for a long time prefer select
committee inquiries
to public inquiries because we get a
faster and
sharper look at a problem
while the evidence is fresh but can i
say
that he i know has been very good
at coming back quickly to members of
parliament and myself in huddersfield in
kirkleese
last week wasn't as good as possible he
didn't give a heads up or it seemed
didn't give a heads up and we were
very much taken aback what were the new
uh
advice given to local authorities like
mine
and but one last point the fact of the
matter is
these pandemics these viruses haven't
gone away
and the disturbing thing that came out
of yesterday's evidence was
there seemed not to have been any
national
plan in this sort of emergency every
local authority
has an emergency uh plan have we now got
one
service well of course we've learnt a
huge amount
about how to respond to a pandemic and
we've built assets and capabilities like
the vaccination program
like the the testing which is so
important both to protect people
directly and break the chains of
transmission and to understand where the
virus
is spreading and i'm glad that we
cleared up the issue that he raised with
respect to
kirkleese and i worked with colleagues
in kirklees and elsewhere
um whilst i was in the west country to
make sure that we got the best possible
solution to the need in kirkleese to
have
turbocharged on the on the vaccination
program to have mass testing
to break the chains of transmission and
for people to be
cautious and take personal
responsibility as we lift the measures
to make sure that things stay under
control and i'm very grateful to him for
what he said about me personally
and i'm very grateful to him for the
leadership he's shown in his community
let's go to dr luke evans luke
yesterday our committee was supposed to
be about lessons learned and in that
spirit
we know that the world's health
organization on the 14th of january
stated there's no human transmission on
the 11th of february
the ho actually named the virus we then
know that on the 14th of february the
european center for disease prevention
and control in update number four
stated that the risk to health systems
in the eu and the uk
was low to moderate and the risk of the
population was low we also know the uk
had a plan
but it was mainly based around flu not
brand new viruses
now obviously look where we are now
isn't the biggest lesson
learned is that we need a global
response and a global resilience plan
so will the health secretary be pushing
the prime minister to make this case
at the g7 when we host it here in the uk
in june
so thank you very much i think that is
one of the lessons i don't need to push
the prime minister on this he's
absolutely seized of the point and we
will be
developing the work on this next week at
the health ministers g7
that is being held in oxford and then of
course
at the leaders summit being held in
cornwall
later next month um the my honourable
friend is absolutely right in the
uh the view that he takes um as to
the importance of reforming and
strengthening the global institutions
as well as learning the lessons here at
home patrick ready thank you mr speaker
he spoke earlier about the donation of
surplus vaccines and other ppe and
medical equipment to india and other
developing countries how does that
square with the government's
determination to cut
its overall contribution to
international aid
is those donations being counted towards
the 0.7 or the 0
0.5 targets it can be assure us that if
it is
that's not going to be to the detriment
of other projects that were already
committed that are towards those targets
so stay the same of course we're
donating uh items directly for instance
to
uh to india uh to nepal and others um
but the single biggest global
contribution that the uk has made
is the oxford vaccine which is being
delivered
at cost by astrazeneca around the world
following funding
from oxford and astrazeneca and the uk
government
you know that has already led to 450
million
jabs globally two-thirds of which are in
lower
and middle-income countries it's
something everybody in all parts of this
country
should be proud of and there was uh
there was there was scottish support in
the development of that vaccine
uh as well um of course we'll we'll do
uh we'll do as much as we can within the
odor budget uh directly
but that decision to waive the ip charge
uh has been called upon from from others
from president biden down
but it's something that we in this house
and the whole country should be very
proud of
find the question steve bryant thank you
sir the vaccine rollout is going really
well
in my area and i can't help but note the
turning of the tide against covid
exactly because of that rollout seemed
to exactly mirror the turning of the
year
isn't it the case mr speaker that far
from the world being divided
into people who are either useless or
brilliant and the british state
failing at every turn we have a
government in this country that did its
best
and a public who came together as always
in the uk when the chips were down
seriously my my um my my honourable
friend
served as a health minister um was a
superb health minister and has captured
not just
uh the uh spirit of what this country
has been through
in the last 18 months but also the
spirit of the debate today
in this house the truth of the matter mr
speaker
is that we work best when we work
together
and we work together when we have a
common
mission and the common mission has been
tackling this
virus and it is absolutely true that we
must always
always do that with an open mind to how
we do it better in the future
but in my view the attitude you need to
take is one
where you welcome people in and you take
things forward
in a spirit of positive partnership
that's how you get stuff done and that's
how we've made the progress we've been
able to make
although i'm now suspending the house
for three minutes to enable
necessarily with the next business
uh i call emily thornbridge to ask your
urgent question
mr speaker for granting this urgent
question can i ask the secretary of
state for international trade to make a
statement
on the united kingdom's proposed tariff
offer to the
australian government on their
agricultural exports minister
mr speaker uh our trade agreement with
australia
is very likely to be the first
from scratch deal that we have struck
outside of the european union
this is a major milestone for global
britain
and a major prize secured for our newly
independent trade policy
it is on course to slash tariffs on
iconic uk exports
saving business potentially around 115
million pounds a year
the deal mr speaker will be the most
advanced that australia has struck with
any nation bar new zealand and will we
expect
be particularly forward leaning in areas
such as services procurement and digital
trade
this will be a great deal for the uk and
our farmers will continue to thrive
the agreement is a gateway into the
massive cptpp
free trade area in asia pacific opening
doors for our farmers
into some of the biggest economies of
now and the future
our food is among the best in the world
and incredibly competitive
we should be positive mr speaker not
fearful
of the opportunities that exist for our
agriculture
and our farmers we give the eu
preferential trading terms which i don't
recall the opposition benches objecting
to
we should be unafraid of giving our
australian cousins something similar
taking the chance to deepen trading ties
with one of our closest friends and
closest allies
australian meet mr speaker is high
quality produced to high standards
and arrives here in low volume meanwhile
australia has some of the highest
animal welfare standards in the world
the uk accounts for just
0.15 percent of australian beef exports
and our analysis suggests any increase
in imports is more likely to displace
food
arriving from the eu any deal we strike
will contain protections for our farmers
any liberalization will be staged over
time and any agreement is likely to
include